[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti grazie di questa
bellissima opportunità anche
responsabilità di iniziare questa
edizione dell'e3 dix siena
io mi chiamo filippo giustini come ho
scritto sul mio profilo linkedin sono
uno strategist e un dreamer per me su mi
hanno sempre avuto un ruolo molto molto
importante nella mia vita e quattro anni
fa ho sognato che volevo trasformare la
mia passione per la comunicazione
marketing nel mio lavoro
suoniamo di farlo con altre persone
quindi di condividere risorse energie e
anche spazi quest'anno dopo un lungo
percorso abbiamo creato in una vecchia
cantina nel nostro il nostro studio non
a colonia immersa nel verde
quello che vedete invece alle spalle un
altro sogno abbiamo avuto nel 2009
quando abbiamo deciso di prenderci una
lunga pausa di 25 giorni durante un
periodo abbastanza complicato da un
punto di vista lavorativo e siamo
partiti per la tunisia e l'algeria
abbiamo fatto un viaggio molto lungo ea
mia moglie insieme altri amici e ci è
successo un po di tutto perché noi siamo
arrivati quasi al confine con il niger
abbiamo spaccato l'albero motore ea
nostra minus e pregato il telaio quando
siamo rientrati in tunisia abbiamo
trovato la guerra civile quindi ad
armati insomma tutto quello poteva
succedere
auto incendiate poi sono saliti
finalmente sulla nave hanno dato fuoco
al porto anche il presidente d'allora
ben ali è scappato con l'aereo è tutta
la famiglia e quindi tutto questo è
successo quando abbiamo deciso per
qualche motivo di uscire dalla nostra
confusione provare a vedere cosa
succedeva al di fuori
io mi sono accorto che la maggior parte
della mia vita oggi è concentrata fuori
da quel puntino quindi fuori da quella
perché è dalla mia con funzione nei
territori nuovi in territori in cui
probabilmente anche tanti limiti
psicologici
bisogna necessariamente superarli
è cambiato un po di cose da da quel
viaggio e ho preso un po alla lettera
questa frase di walt disney quando
diceva è la differenza tra tra un sogno
un obiettivo è semplicemente una data o
decise all'epoca quindi di riordinare un
po i tanti sogni e avevo iniziato a
dargli un po di priorità e raccogliere
un po di energie per capire quale quale
fosse necessario quali strumenti fosse
necessari per realizzarli e quindi gli
stessi su un tavolo da solo insomma un
tavolo mentre ovviamente le mie idee
messo ogni iniziai a ad arci tempo e
delle ac energie quello percorso era un
po tutti
secondo me dobbiamo cercare di fare
seconto quali sono le nostre attitudini
nostre passioni fede per cercare di
capire come come realizzare anche i
nostri nostri progetti
questi sono i progetti di realtà di
altre persone probabilmente molti di
queste conosciamo per le loro
applicazioni oppure per i loro siti
internet
andiamo al bienne be go go pro abbiamo
il software queste sono persone e hanno
un certo momento la loro vita hanno
avuto un'intuizione un idea e hanno
deciso fuori corte ha davanti e
indipendentemente dall'età anagrafica ci
sono riusciti anche in maniera
abbastanza e da tante ma questo non è
che sta a rappresentare che bisogna
puntare a realizzare cose da tanti cosa
importante è cercare di di realizzare
qualcosa è che sentiamo giusto fare
quindi io mi sono accorto il mio
percorso ho fatto tantissime giovani il
momento in cui poi ho deciso di provare
a vedere che succedeva di fuori della
finiamo forgione tanti errori tanti
sbagli anche tante soddisfazioni poi mi
sono consolato un po con questa frase
denis che intanto nel lungo periodo
saremo tutti morti quindi a me mi
consola abbastanza rendermi conto che
tanti errori ho fatto poi alla fine ma
sono così riparabili quello posso
raccontare di me che come diciamo dalle
nostre parti non esistano e salsicce e
infilate nel senso le strade sono molto
difficili e cercare di fare un lavoro
realizzare un proprio progetto non
proprio sogno
ci vuole veramente tanto coraggio e
tanta determinazione e tanta
determinazione fino al punto di negare
anche l'evidenza cioè tanto capiterà che
tutti non smetteranno di credito intorno
a te ti che il tuo progetto la tua idea
ha ragione di esistere e quindi deve
negare e che forse hai sbagliato strada
quindi di continuare a batte la testa
insistere coraggio perché momento in cui
decidiamo di uscire dalla nostra comfort
john diventa diventa tutto un po mistero
cioè iniziamo andare per i tori
inaspettate in cui non esistono più
regole che siamo abituati a pensare
dobbiamo tutto molto più veloce ora
magari sconto con poi lavorare nel
digitale quindi forse sta velocità
neanche molto amplificata però è
necessario può aprirsi e avere sì sì sì
tantissimo coraggio ci vuole tanta forza
anche tanta energia
come diceva carboni ci vuole un fisico
bestiale per fare per fare quello che ci
pare e se non esiste frase canzone più
adatta soprattutto la mia vita
il passato un momento della mia vita che
mettevo la cover su base al mio iphone 3
e mandare email messaggi sotto la doccia
oppure giravano due telefoni ci vuole ci
vuole tanto tanta forza anche in certi
momenti nel momento in cui riesce ok
realizzo quello che mi piace e poi
insomma diventa tutto molto molto molto
faticoso come tante altre
tanti altri lavori quello che però mai
usato e che stavo facendo qualcosa che
mi piaceva quindi quel momento in cui il
sogno poi diventa un progetto può essere
definita un progetto professionale
il fatto di avere questa questa stella
polare e ci indica il cammino c'è meno
me personalmente aiuta a utah ha aiutato
aiuta tuttora tantissimo
non ho mai trovato strada in discesa
quindi ho trovato sempre state molto
molto in salita a tratti pianeggianti e
è diventata leggermente più facile
percorrere questa strada perché comunque
ti rendi conto di essere tu a guidare la
macchina della sua vita e quindi a
prendere decisioni importanti per
cercare di arrivare a questa questa
importante meta me capita anche spesso
di avere ragazzi che si laureano veloce
nei tanti quindi sarà che si laureano
magari ci contattano perché vedo siamo
siamo un'agenzia vicino dove abitano e
ci chiedano semplicemente un consiglio
che sapete cosa fare dopo l'università
io li devo semplicemente cercare di fare
qualcosa a qualcosa che gli piace perché
poi
insomma se dall elemento che ti darà più
forse ti darà più determinazioni in
certi momenti in cui magari se invece
c'è bisogno di dare di più
questa è una frase che noi abbiamo
disegnata in uno dei paesaggi del nostro
studio e mi piace molto perché un po
tuttora cielo te non lo so ma mi disse
fusioni non ti porteranno nessuna parte
i onda ovunque perché poi c'è la fine la
mia vita e quindi siamo abbastanza
orgogliosi sono abbastanza orgoglioso
dei piccoli passi e sto facendo e non
posso farne areole delle opinioni o
delle persone non capiscono quello
quello che faccio semplicemente perché
magari
un deciso di percorre una strada di
realizzare uno più sogni che sono i miei
quindi è naturale che non riescano le
persone a comprendere fino in fondo la
lungimiranza con il quale vedo vedo
certi percorsi gli volevo chiudere con
questa frase è a me come quella del che
nel lungo periodo saremo tutti morti e
sta un po più un po più felice per
prendere un po tutto un po meno sul
serio nel sesso
purtroppo nel lavorare anche nel
progettare mi percorre certe strade ci
sono quantità di variabili che non
possiamo tenere sotto controllo
dobbiamo cercare semplicemente di
ridurre la complessità della realtà per
poter gestire per poter muoversi in
maniera organizzata
quindi sì nel senso la vita comunque
ragione in tutti i casi
indipendentemente dalla quantità di
variabili siamo in grado di controllare
succederà sempre l'imprevisto succederà
sempre qualche cosa di disastroso e non
possiamo farci aree o anche di questa di
questa fatalità e io vi ringrazio che
auguro di poter trovare la vostra strada
ripercorre la con tanta pazienza e con
tanta determinazione
grazie
[Musica]